hello and welcome to the airplane GM
Jasper keep forgetting what that is last
console okay so we have a bird opening
Wow c4 what the heck see find their form
[Music]
so it looks like some kind of sloth with
F for being played so can like see
firemen would be normal i think can also
say it's some kind of green felt it
we're white has played at forum you
don't quite know why so let's see what
happens here trying to get this pawn
back normally white cannot hold such a
pawn some would be quite surprised if he
manages
no I don't see how some 94 maybe and
that was the idea 94 I love it
Wow
wow I'm a little bit to do a shot clear
that that this kind of play can be
possible but it might be okay Tigs 19th
p 897 might work he has lots of material
there okay I can take on c5 it Bishop f7
I don't think this is necessarily bad
for Blackie to be honest but I'm two
pawns down then it's a bit much yeah he
is God he's got lots of porn before that
in this ruined he's got look at them
three pawns and I don't I don't think he
can keep at all of them but would seem
this one okay
I don't like to play be five but maybe I
have to add this a 94 that step the slow
way to do yeah maybe be fine was better
I wasn't really sure him so we'll see
what happens my pieces are still very
active and his King is slightly insecure
not not not so easy so I check here can
you do probably what or do I play this
entirely differently okay but check
let's check first and then see em look
II ate play against you three you on now
this is slow but suck him
okay night age five I don't know if that
leads to much at the end and probably
have to do it ok some
I can take a fourth chikondi for it it
doesn't doesn't entirely convince we
have to do this it looks kind of strange
just a bit surprised that he invests
time you need the night on f5 my deal
was that I might be able to infiltrate
on the tool or here get the night around
currently spawns cannot move that that
easily
and that's it's not easy for white I
mean material wise it's fantastic but
the points don't move not at all f9 f5
can bring the King up a little bit and
then they don't move it seems difficult
for me to me yeah I have bishop f3 I
don't know it's probably it's probably
this probably intended sacrifice I can
also play routine I'm 188 I don't think
I'm going to keep this material right
you probably plan that let's check check
check
some b6 coming up ok b7 can I bring the
King up I can go back to 60 s let's
bring the kin I don't Matt time it's not
good I can do this one b7 I can check on
a five it's a nice trick after capturing
I couldn't catch the catch the point
it's got this one I want to try to play
for a win here I cannot roll them check
check check check check check draw off
her game drawn yeah I don't know that's
really tough one the whole opening was
the whole development in the opening was
kind of wacky so c5 looks extremely
natural to me took it and now all of a
sudden all kinds of hell broke loose
with 95 it's really a shocking move you
had the computer find something which ok
ticks I was also thinking that this that
this might be somewhat variable but it's
two pawns I don't
42 points him okay so we had this and
now I played the droopy aid the engine
wants to take him yeah okay if you if
you can win the night now that's
actually good yeah okay rookie seven
this is miracle chess yeah b6 Bishop e7
okay this is the kind of thing you can
maybe figure out if you have a
tournament game but that's not how it
works in blitz yeah and here yeah yeah I
should go be five I saw the move but I
did not a sin hoped I would get the pawn
just like that this was it was clear to
me that this is okay but I I wanted more
of it made him that was probably a wrong
judgment again be five and now here I'm
not sure it's it's it's really tough
okay 92 winds probably add the night
eyes night is no squares okay that also
wins look at the eighth Wow once you see
it you kind of see the point I am
threatening to take and in a situation
like that they simply no move I'm
threatening this and and windows Wow
okay so this is what I did check yeah
and this is not all that care maybe this
is wrong in 94 and now I decided to to
take and play for the file you have this
one check out at least that gets white
material okay
and here i'm not sure if i have a win or
or not they'll probably probably the
pawns are too strong check out so funny
oh I can actually take it I should have
thought about it for just a moment at
least take rook is a check here I'm
missing too many simple things currently
chatting here that's a draw yeah i'm
gifting away too many points definitely
ok guys thanks for watching